عبرنا يقول هذا الشبيه
ما يقدر يعبر ثلاث مرات يقدر يعبر واحد
يجوز
هذا الرجل ليس الرئيس صدام حسين صدام لم
يعدم ومن تم شنقه كان شبيها له اقاويل
سمعناها كثيرا خلال فتره حكم الرئيس
العراقي الاسبق صدام حسين وما زال صداها
يتردد الى يومنا هذا حتى بعد اعتقاله
ومحاكمته واعدامه
دوبلير الرئيس اسلوب تكتيكي وتمويهي لدى
بعض الزعماء نسجت حوله الروايات وحتى
الاساطير خصوصا عندما يتعلق الامر بزعيم
مثير للجدل ولديه خصوم كثر سواء داخل
دولته ام كاطراف خارجيه
فحتى مع الحراسه والاجراءات الامنيه
المشدده يبقى التعرض للاستهداف او
الاغتيال هارسا يلاحق هؤلاء الزعماء
والتواجد في الاماكن المكشوفه والعامه امر
لا مناص منه احيانا فكان الحل باللجوء الى
الشبيه او الدب
صدام حسين كان ولا يزال ماده دسمه لتلك
الروايات تقارير وشهادات كثيره تحدثت عن
اللجوء صدام لشخص شديد الشبه به يدعى
مخائل رمضان صالح ويقال ان الاستخبارات
العراقيه انذاك قامت بتدريبه على تقمص
شخصيه الرئيس ويشاع ايضا ان مخائيل لم يكن
الدوبليرا الوحيده لصدام وانه كان هناك
عده اشخاص يقومون بهذا الدور وانا نجله
عديل جاء كذلك الى شبيه يحل مكانه في بعض
المناسبات
اليوم عاد الحديث عن فرضيه وجود دوبلر لكن
هذه المره لزعيم اخر ليس اقل اثاره للجدل
من صدام انه زعيم الكرملين الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين في التاسعه عشر من شهر
مارس عام 2023
ظهر الرئيس الروسي يتجول في شوارع مدينه
ماريوبل التي سيطرت عليها الروسيه في شرق
اوكرانيا في زياره مفاجئه لم يعلن عنها
الكرملين الا بعد مغادره بوتين المدينه
بوتين او احد النسخ المطابقه له نفذ زياره
ليليه للمنطقه المحتله
بعض المسؤولين الاوكراني شككوا حينها فيما
اذا كان هذا الزائر هو حقا بوتين او نسخه
طبق الاصل عنه وهي ادعاءات ليست بجديده في
اكتوبر عام 2022 ادعى الرئيس الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه بان الرئيس الروسي
استخدموا اشخاصا خضعوا لجراحات تجميليه
ليصبحوا يشبهونه تماما
كشفنا اشباه بوتين في الماضي عملوا لصالحه
في مناسبات خاصه لكنها ممارسه معتاده الان
نحن نعلم على وجه التحديد بشان ثلاثه
اشخاص يستمرون في الظهور ولكن كم يبلغ
عددهم جميعا لا نعرف
كذلك الامر مع زعيم كوريا الشماليه كيم
جون جون الذي يشاع انه يستخدم دوبليرا
شبيها به في بعض المناسبه
لكن سؤاله هنا كيف يميز المختصون الشخص
الحقيقي من الشرير
هناك عده اجزاء من الجسم يمكن ان تكشف
هويه الشخص وباستخدام تطبيقات وبرامج
حديثه يمكن للاذن ان تكشفه هويه الشخص
بمعدل دقه اعلى من بصمه الاصابع اضافه الى
فارق الطول حتى لو كان بسيطه وعلامات اخرى
كشكل الفك السفلي
اليوم ومع التقدم الكبير في مجال جراحات
التجميليه اصبحت امكانيه وجود نسخه طبق
الاصل لزعيم ما اكثر واقعيه لكن ورغم كل
ذلك الحديث حول هذا الامر لا يزال يندرج
ضمن الاقاويل والادعات
فهل تصدقونها